لا ننصحك بريطانيا بهذه الخطوات فصبرنا
بدا ينفد وردنا سيكون ردا نوويا هكذا صرخ
بها بوتين وتحالف بكين وموسكو يعطي النيتو
مهله اخيره ومئه الف جندي اوكراني يتحضرون
للهجوم الكارتي وكرد على زياره بوتين
ماريوبول هو زيلينسكي يظهر في باخموت
واشنطن تضع اول قاعده عسكريه امريكيه
دائمه بالقرب من روسيا فكيف سيرد بوتين
وتايوان تحضر خطه لمواجهه الصين عسكريا
والجزائر تعلن انفصال مصير علاقتها مع
المغرب فهل هناك بصيص امل للعوده وتركيا
تعتذر للعراق لينبض شريان الحياه من جديد
ومفاعل نووي روسي يصل مصر والاردن تصوت
على طرد السفير الاسرائيلي من اراضيها رد
روسي مزلزل
انكشفت الاوراق الغربيه وبات الغرب على
مرمى نيران مواجهه روسيا وبينما كانت
الحرب الكبرى تطبخ على نار هادئه فجاه
استيقظ الدب الروسي ليقول كفى الى هنا
وحسب وبعد ان اعلنت بريطانيا الناس تزود
اوكرانيا بقذائف تحتوي على يورانيوم مخصب
الرد الروسي لا يتاخر وعلى لسان وزير
الخارجيه الروسيسركي حيث صرح قائلا ان
تزويدا لندن بقذائف اليورانيوم ياخذ الوضع
لمستوى خطير جديد نعم التوترات على اشدها
يا ساده وكل يدلو بدلوه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يبدا معارك الرد بقوله ان
خطوه مد اوكرانيا بقذاء فكها دليل على نيه
الغرب لمحاربه روسيا بالفعل ليضيف
للرد المناسب اذا تم ارسال اسلحه ذات
مكونات نوويه لكياب فهل وصلت رساله بوتين
ايها الغربيون وفي الطرف الاخر الرئيس
البيلاروسي لوكيشنكي يصرح قائلا
فليفعلواها ان كانوا مجالنا الى هذا الحد
حينها لن نرحم احدا وسيكون رد روسيا
مزلزلا الرد البريطاني جاء على لسان وزير
الخارجيه جيمس كليفل الذي قال انه لا يوجد
تصعيد نووي وان الدوله الوحيده التي تتحدث
عن القضايا النوويه هي روسيا بحسب تعبيره
ليظهر رئيس الوزراء السابق لايطاليا
جوزيبي كونتي معبرا عن غضبه من بريطانيا
واوروبا بقوله لم يصدر احد فيه ايطاليا
اوروبا بيانا بنفسه عن حليفنا البريطاني
الذي اعلن عن ارسال قذائف اليورانيوم المن
هذا يزيد من تاجيج الوضع في اوكرانيا هنا
الروس يساعدون من لهجتهم نعم ها هو نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجيريا يوجه
بوصلته نحو امريكا قائلا ان واشنطن تواصل
اجراءات معاديه نشيطه ضد روسيا ليس فقط في
اوكرانيا بل ان واشنطن تلعب بالنار بشان
مساله العوده الى معاهده
في مناقشه حول ما اذا كان احتمال نشوب
صراع النووي مرتفعا هذه الايام ولكن على
ايه
الاحتماليه اعلى من اي مرحله شهدناها خلال
العقود الاخيره وفق تعبيره
توترات من جديد بقوله ان قرار واشنطن
مواصله تحليق طائراتها فوق البحر الاسود
يدفع روسيا لاتخاذ اجراء المواجهه محذرا
واشنطن من اختبار صبر موسكو ليوجه رساله
مباشره للنيتو هذه المره حين قال ان اعضاء
الكونجرس الامريكي الذين يطالبون بتزويد
بالذخائر العنقوديه لا يدركون ما هي
العواقب المحتمله على النيتو ولا زلنا في
روسيا حيث غادر الرئيس الصيني موسكو بعد
زياره رسميه استمرت عده ايام لكن هذه
الزياره حملت طياتها كثيرا مما يرعب
الامريكيين فزياره
مفادها لست وحدك يا بوتين في حين تعهد
الطرفين لبعضهما بالتعاون على جميع
المستويات السياسيه والاقتصاديه وحتى
العسكريه والتكنولوجيه لكن الهدف الاسمى
هو اعلان انتهاء حكم القطب الواحد للعالم
ومرحبا بعالم متعد اقطاب كما يقولها
الصينيون والروس وفي البيان الختامي لقمه
شيجيم بينغ وبوتين شددت موسكو وبكين على
ضروره ان يتقيد النيتو بالطابع الدفاعي
وان يحترم سياده الدول الاخرى ليصرح بوتين
بان خطه السلام الصينيه قد تكون اساسا
للتسويه في اوكرانيا عند جاهزيه كييف
والغرب مضيفا ان الغرب يريد ان يحارب
روسيا حتى اخر اوكرانيا لكن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه كان رده مسبقا وذلك بدعوته
العالم لعدم الانخداع باي تحرك من جانب
الصين لوقف الحرب بشروط روسيا الخاصه
مطالبا بكين باستخدام نفوذها لاجبار موسكو
على سحب القوات الروسيه من اوكرانيا
الخارجيه الصينيه لم تصمت ورده على الفور
بان على الولايات المتحده اعاده في دورها
في الصراع الاوكراني والتوقف عن القاء
اللوم على الصين وهنا تعلن واشنطن ان خير
وسيله للدفاع هي الهجوم ليتم الاعلان عن
اول قاعده عسكريه امريكيه دائمه في بولندا
الهدف من التنسيق مع قوات النيتو في تحول
لافت للدوري البولندي فبولندا تحولت من
حليف رئيسي للاتحاد السوفيتي الى راس حربه
في قوات النيتو لمواجهه روسيا ومن ضجيج
الحروب الكلاميه الى اصوات المدافع
والطائرات في اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط مروحيه اوكرانيه من
طراز من اي بي منطقه خركوف و26 طائره
مسيره في جمهوريه
واضافت الوزاره الروسيه انه تم تصفيه اكثر
من 100
جنديا اوكرانيا من جهته زيلينسكي لم يقف
مكتوف اليدين وتحرك لزياره الخطوط
الاماميه بالقرب من بخموت وفق راوترز
وهناك قال يشرفني ان نكون هنا في الشرق
اليوم واكرم افضل الابطال لكن زياره
الرئيس الاوكراني كان قد سبقها اعلان
مستشار القائم باعمال رئيس جمهوريه دونتسك
الشعبيه ان مدينه ارتيموفسكي اي بخموت قد
اصبحت محاصره تماما
الصين شوكه في ظهر امريكا
الامريكانو يدخلون الصين في كل شارده
ووارده وهل يمر يوم واحد للولايات المتحده
دون ذكر بكين هنا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
يقول ان الصين لم تصل الى حد تسليم اسلحه
فتاكه لروسيا بعد في اطار الحرب
الاوكرانيه مؤكدا ان الاداره الامريكيه لم
ترا ان الصين تجاوزت ذلك الخط فماذا لو
تجاوزته يا هذا لننتقل الى الوجبه الصينيه
القادمه نعم انها تايوان ومع اجراء رئيسه
تايوان زياره الى الولايات المتحده
وامريكا الوسطى الاسبوع المقبل قال نائب
وزير الدفاع التايواني ان وزاره الدفاع
التايواني لديها خطط طوارئ لاي تحركات من
جانب الصين خلال هذه الفتره بحسب رويترز
اي خلال غياب التايوانيه
الاحداث والتطورات قال الرئيس الجزائري
عبد المجيد تبون ان العلاقات مع المغرب
وصلت الى نقطه لا عوده مضيفا انه ياسف على
وصل العلاقه بين البلدين الجارين الى هذا
المستوى اليس هناك طريق اخر يا ابناء
الصحراء صوت البرلمان الاردني بالموافقه
على توصيه للحكومه بطرد السفير الاسرائيلي
من عمان وذلك ردا على الوزير الاسرائيلي
الذي قال ان خريطه اسرائيل تضم الاردن
وفلسطين رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني في تركيا رغم الخلافات واردوغن
اكدنا عزمنا على العمل معا لانجاز مشروع
طريق التنميه رامي لبناء ممر نقل بري وسكه
حديد تمتد من البصره الى تركيا مضيفا ان
طريقه تنميه لا يعتبر مشروع الاستراتيجيا
مهما لتركيا والعراق فحسب بل للمنطقه
باسرها وهنا عاد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ليبشر العراقيين ان بلاده اتخذت
قرارا بزياده كميه المياه لنهر دجله لمده
شهر واحد من اجل رفع ضائقه العراق لكنه
قال انه يتوقع بالمقابل من العراق
الاعتراف
انها ارهابي اعتذار مشروط يا اهل العراق
فهل تقبلون اعلنت شركه روسيا الروسيه عن
وصول اول معده كبيره الحجم مصياده قلب
المفاعل النووي الى موقع بناء محطه الضبعه
النوويه في جمهوريه مصر العربيه خطر الحرب
النوويه يعود من جديد بسبب دعم بريطاني
لاوكرانيا فهل يكون الانجليز سببا في حرب
كهذه
[موسيقى]